hey guys it's inka and in this video i
will only be eating
red colored foods for 24 hours so we're
getting to the end of the rainbow here
red is a color that a lot of you have
been requesting
so i figured now is the time to finally
make it happen
as per usual i will only be making and
eating foods that are naturally colored
red
and hopefully i will be able to create
these red themed dishes
that are both visually satisfying and
also very appetizing because of safety
reasons
i will be doing most of my shopping
online but i really wanted to stop by
the grocery store just to see if there's
anything cool
so let's go shopping really quickly
red pepper
[Music]
coloring
good morning everyone it is a new day i
am in
my red colored shirt it is more of a
maroon
kind of like the color of red wine i am
ready to start off my
red color day for some reason it feels
like i'm celebrating valentine's
but here we go i have some red dragon
fruit
this is truly one of my favorite fruits
i think it's really popular for people
to put it in their smoothie bowls now
because of its vibrant color
i have this pear that is actually a
beautiful red on the outside
some raspberries some strawberries
salami a cranberry cheese
red pepper jelly you can see that it's
literally a bright red
it doesn't use any artificial coloring i
think the red mainly comes from the
sweet red peppers
it's supposed to go well on cheese and
meat so i'm excited to test it out i'm
just going to wash the fruit really
quickly it's already looking super red
i love it i'm also going to slice up my
dragon fruits
look at this color wow this is also why
some people use red dragon fruit as a
natural
dye because look at how pigmented it is
the same thing with my berries
pear open this cheese okay i definitely
smell the cranberry so i know this isn't
completely red but i think it qualifies
to a certain extent
whoa this it smells super pungent wow it
is spicy it smells so spicy i think i'm
smelling like the vinegar so there's
like that
huge like sour note it is
literally a bright red scoop it out like
that
this is kind of the texture i am now
going to put this on top of my
cheese and then i should be done
breakfast
is served you can see the strawberries
here the red dragon fruit the raspberry
on this side you'll be able to see the
pear at the bottom the salami
the cheese and then the red pepper jelly
it looks more like a charcuterie board
but i don't think that's a bad thing
let's dig in let's try that it's like a
burst of berry flavor
if you've never tried red dragon fruit i
could not recommend it enough
it has more of like a neutral flavor i
feel so it complements
every other fruit that you have it with
i'm gonna go ahead and try
my little creation here with the pear
salami cranberry cheese
and jelly i still smell the red pepper
jelly oh my god
it's actually pretty good the jelly is
not spicy
the cheese is super super creamy a
little bit of savoriness from the salami
it had like that tartness from the pear
i'm gonna try the jelly by itself
huh it's a very very faint spiciness at
the back of your throat i'm mainly
getting like a sweet and sour flavor
i honestly just feel like i'm having a
fancy cheese board
in one bite everything kind of just
works out that was really enjoyable so
i'm gonna finish up what's left on my
plate there's really not much left i
might pop out a little bit
later to get a bottle of red wine for
lunch
see you guys then just got my bottle of
wine so i'm heading back home now
to start working on lunch i have my
bottle of red wine right here
red colored foods immediately made me
think of tomato sauce
which is one of my go-to pasta sauces so
that's what i'll be making today i tried
to keep it simple this time so there's
only a few ingredients canned tomatoes
here i love the fire roasted ones tomato
paste
this is the key ingredient to making it
super red red onion
red bell pepper apple for sweetness this
pasta
that's made out of beets tuna i'm not
entirely sure how i'm going to
incorporate this into my meal yet i'll
find a way to put this in there and of
course i also have my red wine
i feel like this meal should be pretty
good i am missing some of my usual
ingredients like my herbs and
garlic but i think i should be able to
make this work gonna start off by
cooking this pasta almost like a
purplish red once it hit the water it
immediately became this like
super pretty red it looks like twizzlers
start cutting up my vegetables i know
some of you might be thinking that it's
really weird to add apple into your
sauces but
i do do it sometimes usually for stews
and soups because i like the natural
sweetness it adds
so i'm doing a little bit of
experimenting today i'm gonna go ahead
and toss them in the pan
and add the tomato paste tomato
this is beginning to look like a sauce
already i'm just gonna go ahead and add
some paprika
as well as some cayenne pepper now to
add in my wine
i have some pasta water it's super red
as well so
i'm just gonna add that back in it's
looking good toss
my pasta in here as for what i'm
smelling right now
i'm just getting a lot of red wine and
tomato i may have
put more wine than i intended and for my
tuna i'm just going to sear it as a hoe
and then slice it up
still perfectly red on the inside i like
that we can still
see the red meat for those of you who
are concerned i promise
this piece of fish is safe to eat raw so
don't worry the pasta is pretty much
done i'm just gonna make a drink really
quick
just some watermelon juice so i'm gonna
blend up some fresh watermelon and then
i'm ready to eat
this is my red lunch for the day it is
super red which i'm really happy about
tuna on the top the little bit of radish
pasta itself just looks so red
that it's almost a little bit
intimidating then i also have my
watermelon juice
i am just going to go ahead and take a
big bite of this
so good i was a little skeptical because
i'm usually somebody who's super heavy
on the garlic but there's still a lot of
flavor
the red wine is a really great addition
it adds a lot of depth really strong
peppery smell peppery as in like red
bell pepper look at this tuna
isn't it so beautiful
i don't know if it pairs the best with
pasta but i enjoy tuna a lot
just as it is the watermelon juice is so
refreshing
i am really enjoying this meal
surprisingly i didn't know red colored
food would be the one that would give me
this much enjoyment now i'm gonna turn
off the cameras and finish the rest of
my meals slowly
check back in later it's around 4 p.m
right now i am just sitting on the couch
to rest for a little bit mostly to rest
my eyes
but i figured now would be a good time
to eat some snacks i found this at hmart
yesterday it is basically a savory
snack that is similar to dopoki which is
just korean rice cakes but in chip form
the red pigment mainly comes from
paprika
and red chili paste it looks so similar
to a rice cake but not like flaming hot
cheetos kind of bright red it smells
like a fry
hmm it's like much more on the sweeter
side than i was expecting which is
probably why i like it ooh okay there is
a bit of a spice afterwards it kind of
hits you out of nowhere
i really miss being able to go around
the office and make everybody else try
this before i finish that whole bag i
also have this other treat
it says sweet rice cake on the package
also known as
dongo this one specifically is made with
red bean
[Music]
i should have saved this for dessert
this is what it looks like the red beans
kind of squished
i'm a huge fan of that like cucu chewy
texture
and the red bean is just right for this
sweetness these are some great snacks
and we'll shave the rest for later
definitely feeling more energized now
that i have summer few in my system
i am now going to work a little bit more
and then
soon i'll get started on preparing
dinner and i don't want to jinx it but i
feel like it's been a pretty good day so
far
dinner time is just around the corner so
i am back in the kitchen
also i was thinking for red colored
foods considering how many spicy things
there are under this category
maybe i should try to make a very spicy
dish
so that's what i'm going to be doing for
this meal i have some
beef over here red potatoes harissa
which is a tunisian
hot chili pepper paste so it has a lot
of flavor in it there's this
really vivid red and since i'm stepping
up the spice game i have a bunch of thai
red chilies here
they may be the death of me gochujang
which is korean hot pepper paste
you can see the edges how bright that is
i also found this red rice i've heard of
red rice but i've never
had the opportunity to taste it so today
is the day
i also have some gochugaru which is just
some korean red pepper powder
and this thing is usually what gives
that
huge fiery kick i'll be a little
heavy-handed on this today i think the
plan for dinner is essentially for me to
make
a very spicy meat and potato stew
hopefully i don't cry when i'm eating
this
i'm going to cook some rice natural
looking brownish red but i'm gonna go
ahead and wash it let it soak and then
cook it over the stovetop boil my
potatoes
i'm also just going to sear my beef i am
going to make
my fiery red hot sauce i love this sauce
but
literally the moment you open it you can
smell
the spice if you're afraid of spice this
might terrify you
they got the red pepper powder oh this
smells so good
mix it together i'm having a lot of fun
putting this together
but i think i might pay for it later
which is like the sauce from the
underworld
all of this color you're seeing right
here it is completely natural i'm gonna
give this sauce a try
it is very spicy like i can feel it in
the back of my throat right now wow am i
gonna lose my voice because of this
i love spicy food though so
i think this is gonna be fun but now i'm
gonna start frying up the onions first
a little bit of chili now i'm a little
scared red potatoes have once again
become more brown than red i'm just
going to cut them up
toss them in the pot beef is in as well
now it is now time to add in
my fire sauce mixing that in
i feel like it's looking more orange
than red though so i'm gonna add in
maybe a little more gochujang i'm gonna
let it chill
got my rice going in the background it's
been around half an hour it is
slightly more orange than i like and to
be honest i'm a little terrified because
i kept on thinking it's not red enough
it's not red enough so i kept on adding
red pepper powder red pepper sauce chili
flakes so
i shall suffer the consequences and then
i have my red rice at the back here
which means that dinner is now pretty
much done and i am ready to serve it all
up and
this is what i have i know it doesn't
look as extravagant as my other meals
the sauce has really been cooked down so
then you can't even see the potatoes
anymore
but with that being said i do feel like
the flavor in this one
is going to be pretty intense a little
nervous actually i should probably
get my drink ready it is a kombucha that
i made
pomegranate and strawberry in there
maybe i'll start off with something
sweet
refreshing slightly fizzy this rice
definitely has more of like a wild rice
texture we're just gonna scoop a big
bite here
cheers everybody
it's really spicy
it's really spicy oh my god
am i gonna cry oh my god like i feel
like in the beginning when i first
tasted the sauce right
because i went a little crazy trying to
make the color right
now it is it is like fire
is this how people feel on like hot ones
well
you know what i'm gonna try another bite
i will say that eating with the beef is
pretty nice because
the meat has so much surface area i
think the harissa
was a really nice way of like kind of
binding everything together because it
has so many spices built into it a
potato at this point too has already
been coaxed down so much
that the sauce has become this like
thicker consistency
but i feel like if you like spice this
really isn't a bad idea at all you just
might have to pay for it the next day
you know
i am going to transition right into
dessert because that's going to help me
cool off
this burning sensation on my tunnel
right now i have some
ice cream with me this is just a
strawberry guava sorbet
it's this like pinkish red color and it
will save me from the paint i'm in right
now and i eat enough to cool it down
[Music]
maybe that was too big of a mouthful i'm
not having a brain freeze does help
soothe the pain
but it is freezing the brain i love this
flavor though
super refreshing fruity can't go wrong
with sorbets today was quite the
adventure i feel like i had some pretty
amazing meals and then i also had meals
that were
good but also tortured me a little bit i
think we pretty much only have two
colors left now orange and white
correct me if i'm wrong but let me know
which one you guys want to see next
and i will see you guys then bye
[Music]
you